[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
2 september
1999 Long Island das Paradies für viele
Pendler und Stadtmühle New Yorker Heimat
zahlreicher prominenter im Ortsteil
jerico wohnt zum Beispiel Natalie
Portman die 18-Jährige hat gerade die
Highschool beendet und wo gerade mal
vier Monaten kam Star Wars Episode 1 in
die Kinos in dem Sie als Partner Amidala
Königin von NABU zu sehen ist nur ein
paar Ecken vom Haus ihre Eltern entfernt
hat Ronald Cohen gerade das Haus seiner
Familie für 455
000 $ verkauft jetzt sind noch ein paar
Aufräumarbeiten zu erledigen es kommt
einiges für die Müllabfuhr zusammen kein
Problem bis auf das 200 l Fass im
crossbase das ist dieser flache Keller
den kennt man wahrscheinlich aus den
amerikanischen Filmen dieser Keller in
dem man nicht aufrecht stehen kann der
direkt unter dem Haus ist man kann nur
Griechen also Quallen
er dient meist als Zugang zum Fundament
und zu den installations- und
wartungseinrichtungen von Rohrleitungen
Klimaanlagen elektroverteilern und
ähnlichem und natürlich oft genug als
Stauraum für Dinge die man vermutlich
nie wieder braucht aber vielleicht ja
irgendwann mal brauchen könnte oder von
denen man sich aus anderen Gründen nicht
trennen will oder kann das Fass ist kaum
aus dem crows besser rauszubekommen so
schwer ist es Ronald Korn hat keine
Ahnung was darin ist das lag schon unter
dem Haus als er es gekauft hat der
Vorbesitzer wusste auch nicht was darin
steckt er habe es schon vom vorvorigen
Besitzer übernommen immer wieder mal im
kauen sich vor sich nun endlich darum zu
kümmern aber naja es gehört ja auch
nicht direkt dummerweise besteht der
neue Käufer darauf dass es entfernt wird
jetzt muss Kohnen sich darum kümmern das
Fass ist groß und wiegt verdammt viel
aber irgendwie bekommt er es da raus und
stellt es an die Straße nur leider
weigert sich die Müllabfuhr es
mitzunehmen es ist viel zu schwer
außerdem könnten ja giftige Chemikalien
drin sein die anders entsorgt werden
müssen Ronald Korn holt Werkzeug und
stimmt das fast auf und sieht eine Hand
mit einem Ring
[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland ich bin Stefan Netzeband
heute in Vertretung unserer beiden
krimi-königin Toni und Natalie und ich
bin Mirko Kasimir und wahrscheinlich
habt ihr sofort geahnt dass in dem
geheimnisvollen Fass im Keller keine
schöne Überraschung wartet ich meine
allein dieser Keller dieser crawl space
ich weiß nicht wie viele Filme und
Serien ich gesehen habe in denen ein
Kind oder der Vater da unten
herumkriecht ich erinnere mich auch eine
sehr lustige Folge von Modern Family wo
sie sich da unten gruseln und dann ein
Monster begegnen oder vielleicht sogar
einer Mumie wäre fast schon so ein
abgedroschen ist Horror Klischee dass
man in der Film natürlich häufiger zu
sehen bekommt irgendjemand der kriecht
oder kletterte irgendwo rein und die
Musik wird immer bedrohlicher im
Hintergrund und dann BAM es ist doch nur
eine weglaufende Katze schön wärs aber
1999 war es kein einfallsloses Drehbuch
sondern bitte eure Realität die Polizei
findet in dem fast die mumifizierte
Leiche einer jungen Frau
[Musik]
die Untersuchung ergibt dass sie mit
mehreren Schlägen auf den Kopf getötet
wurde
ungewöhnliche Goldkronen an ihren Zähnen
deuten darauf hin dass sie nicht in den
USA geboren und aufgewachsen ist sondern
möglicherweise in Südamerika das
grausigste Detail aber ist dass sie zum
Zeitpunkt ihres Todes im 9 Monat
schwanger gewesen ist sie trägt einen
männlichen Fötus im Leib ihren Sohn der
mit ihr ermordet wurde bevor er zur Welt
kam okay aber es sollte nicht so schwer
sein den Mörder zu finden oder
ganz so einfach ist die Sache dann aber
doch nicht die Polizei befragt frühere
Eigentümer des Hauses ohne aber konkrete
Anhaltspunkte zu finden es ist klar wann
die Frau ermordet wurde man vermutet
etwa 20 bis 30 Jahre zuvor aber da
besteht anfangs Unsicherheit es gelingt
zu Beginn auch nicht dass Mordopfer zu
identifizieren die Leiche passt zu
keiner vermissten Person aus dem
fraglichen Zeitraum und das Adressbuch
dass man zum Glück ebenfalls in der
Tonne findet das ist von der Zeit und
von all den Flüssigkeiten da drin völlig
unleserlich und dann ist da noch eine
Rose keine echte Rose eine plastikblume
aber erst einmal kann niemand etwas mit
dir anfangen dafür nehmen die Forensiker
das Adressbuch noch mal genauer unter
die Lupe bzw unter den Video special
Komparator damals absolut state of the
art wenn es darum geht versteckte
verblichene oder sonst wie zerstörte
Schriften wieder lesbar zu machen ein
Computer zwei digitale Videokameras
sowie diverse Licht und
Strahlungsquellen können erstaunliches
leisten sie machen auch das Adressbuch
der unbekannten Toten wieder lesbar
anfangs scheint es eine Sackgasse zu
sein die Telefonnummern sind Jahrzehnte
alt sie stammen aus einer Zeit vor den
zwischen fast allgegenwärtigen
Mobiltelefonen mal heißt es kein
Anschluss unter dieser Nummer mal ist
der Anschluss neu vergeben an Leute die
natürlich nicht weiterhelfen können doch
schließlich erreichen sie eine Frau
namens Katie Andrews und sie weiß sofort
warum es geht und um wen
1969 Katie lebt im John auf Arkham einem
katholischen Frauenheim in Manhattan und
lernt dort eine junge Frau kennen Rainer
marokkin 28 Jahre Rena stammt aus als
Salvador nach einer gescheiterten ist
sie in die Vereinigten Staaten emigriert
schon immer war sie von den USA
fasziniert vor allem von New York jetzt
will sie den amerikanischen Traum wahr
machen sie lernt Englisch studiert Mode
und belegt Kurse für die
Staatsbürgerschaft sie liebt Musik sie
hat einen Job sie hat viele Freunde doch
Katie wird bald ihre beste Freundin
Katie weiß dass sie auch einen Liebhaber
hat doch Rena will er den Namen nicht
nennen er ist verheiratet sagt sie immer
wieder aber er wird seine Frau verlassen
und mit mir zusammen zu leben oh je
merke ich weiß nicht wie es Dir geht
aber kennst du auch nur eine einzige
Geschichte in der dieser Satz vorkommt
die ein Happy End hatte am Ende also mir
fällt keins sein und dass das hier und
das dies hier keins hat ja das wissen
wir ja leider jetzt schon
irgendwann bemerkt Katie dass ihre
glückliche hoffnungsvolle Freundin ihre
Trainer sich verändert sie fragt sie ob
sie Probleme habe ob sie bei irgendwas
helfen können und schließlich Beichte
Trainer dass sie schwanger ist aber der
Mann der Vater würde jetzt ganz bestimmt
seine Frau verlassen um mit ihr
zusammenzuleben sie scheint es selbst
nicht mehr zu glauben als die Polizei
1999 mit Katie spricht erinnert die sich
an die Tränen und die Verzweiflung ihrer
Freunde der Name des Vaters gibt Rena
noch immer nicht Preis immerhin kümmert
er sich um sie er besorg dir einen Arzt
und eine Wohnung in New Jersey aber
seine Familie will er natürlich nicht
verlassen und dann an einem Tag im
Januar 1969 ruft oder Ina bei Katie an
sie ist panisch und in Tränen aufgelöst
sie haben etwas Schreckliches getan sagt
sie ihrer Freundin sie habe im Haus
ihres Geliebten angerufen und seiner
Frau von der Affäre und ihrer
Schwangerschaft erzählt
sehr sehr mutige Idee vielleicht aber
keine gute jetzt hat Rena Angst er wird
mich töten ruft sie ins Telefon Katie
versucht sie zu beruhigen niemand werde
sie töten aber Rainer beharrt darauf
doch er sagt er bringt mich um Katie
macht sich auf den Weg nach New Jersey
als sie die Wohnung ihrer Freundin
erreicht ist die Tür nur angelehnt sie
klopft als niemand antwortet betritt sie
zögern das Apartment auf dem Herd steht
warmes Essen der Wintermantel hängt an
der Garderobe Handschuhe Stiefel
Brieftasche alles ist da nur Rena fehlt
Katie wartet vier Stunden auf die
Rückkehr ihrer Freundin dann geht sie
zur Polizei die schickt sie aber wieder
weg weil sie keine Angehörige sei und es
keine Hinweise auf ein Verbrechen gäbe
die ist wahrscheinlich mit ihrem Freund
abgehauen sagen die Beamten die ist bald
wieder da ist sie nicht
Katie gibt den Versuch einer
Vermisstenanzeige bald auf und tröstet
sich mit dem Gedanken dass Rena
wahrscheinlich nach El Salvador
zurückgegangen ist um das Baby dort bei
ihrer Familie zu bekommen und groß zu
ziehen das Opfer ist identifiziert wir
sind also wieder im Jahr 99 nur der
Mörder ist noch immer unbekannt aber die
Untersuchung des Fasses in dem Reiners
Leiche gefunden wurde hat inzwischen
entscheidende Hinweise geliefert da ist
zum einen die plastikblume außerdem
findet man Polystyrol Pellets und diese
werden unter anderem verwendet und
Plastikblumen herzustellen dazu Reste
von grüner Farbe wie sie ebenfalls in
der Herstellung künstlicher Blumen
verwendet wird und die spezielle Tonne
selbst wird er den frühen 70er Jahren
nicht mehr hergestellt was den möglichen
Tatzeitpunkt weiter eingrenzt der erste
Besitzer des Hauses war Hauert Elkins
mit Inhaber einer Fabrik für
Plastikblumen
[Musik]
er hat das Haus
1973 verkauft und die Ermittlungen haben
ergeben dass der Mord vor diesem
Zeitpunkt geschehen sein muss die
Polizei hat also einen Verdächtigen
erkans lebt inzwischen zusammen mit
seiner Frau Ruth in einer
Seniorenresidenz in Florida am 9
September 1999 bekommt der Besuch von
zwei Ermittlern die ihn befragen wollen
anfangs zeigt er sich kooperativ gibt
sogar zu dass er eine Affäre mit einer
Angestellten seiner Fabrik gehabt habe
er könne sich aber weder an ihren Namen
noch an ihr Aussehen erinnern als die
Beamten ihn um eine DNA-Probe bitten um
sie mit der DNA des Fötus zu vergleichen
weigert er sich dann ruft seine Frau an
er bittet die Detektive zu gehen Bruce
komme gleich nach Hause und er habe eine
Menge Dinge mit ihr zu besprechen die
Beamten gehen und kündigen an am
nächsten Tag mit einem Gerichtsbeschluss
für eine DNA Probe zurückzukommen
am nächsten Tag ist Howard Elkins
verschwunden dabei hatten die Ermittler
trotz der erdrückenden Indizien auf eine
Verhaftung verzichtet weil sie keine
Fluchtgefahr sahen doch hault Elkins ist
nicht geflohen naja eigentlich doch
zumindest vor der Verantwortung und den
Konsequenzen ja das stimmt natürlich
sein Sohn findet ihn im Auto des
Nachbarn in dessen Garage Howard Elkins
ist tot zwischen den Beinen steht die
Schrotflinte die er sich tags zuvor nach
dem Besuch der Beamten in einem Walmart
gekauft hat was genau an jedem Tag im
Januar 1969 geschehen ist wird also nie
ganz aufgeklärt werden die Ermittler
vermuten dass Elkins seine Geliebte
besuchte sie unter einem Vorwand in die
Fabrik lockte und dort erschlug dagegen
wiederum spricht der Zustand in dem
Katie die Wohnung gefunden hat die
angelehnte Tür das warme Essen auf dem
Herd die unberührten Wintersachen wie
gesagt die Frage kann nie ganz geklärt
werden er kennt besitzt ein Boot die
Ermittler gehen daher davon aus dass
Elkins die Leiche in das große fast
packt um sie später im Meer verschwinden
zu lassen
doch genau wie viele Jahre danach Ronald
Cohen muss auch eher feststellen dass es
viel zu schwer ist um es allein auf sein
Boot zu bringen und so landet es im
crossbase und er seinem Haus wo es drei
Jahrzehnte darauf wartet sein
schreckliches Geheimnis preiszugeben
also merke ich weiß nicht wie es Dir
geht aber das ist doch schon irre oder
der sitzt da mit seiner Familie
jahrelang auf diesen Fass und dann
verkauft er das Haus und zieht einfach
weg und denkt nicht mehr daran er hatte
wahrscheinlich vor sich irgendwann mal
drum zu kümmern und vielleicht sogar
unterschwellig gehofft dass ich das
Problem ja von alleine lösen könnte so
nach dem Motto was ich nicht sehen kann
dass existiert auch nicht also sagen wir
mal so Dinge verschlucken und sie dann
erfolgreich aus aus dem Alltag
verbringen das beherrsche ich auch sehr
gut ja aber da Leiche drin das würde ich
glaube ich nicht verdrängt bekommen das
muss doch an einem nagen und spätestens
ab dem Zeitpunkt wo er das verkauft das
Haus da muss er doch Angst gehabt haben
dass der nächste Besitzer sich kümmert
und dann alles rauskommt also mir geht's
schon schlecht wenn ich das diese
Verdrängung machen mit Steuererklärung
oder Zahnarztbesuch her aber die Nummer
da so und und jetzt wir schmunzeln auch
ein Stück zurecht aber der Fall ist
natürlich die ernste
schwangere Frau erschlagen ja die Sache
mit dem Fass ist wirklich das
rätselhafteste an diesem Fall vielleicht
nicht mal der Mord selber leider denn so
schrecklich das auch ist Frauenmorde
also femizide sind leider ein immer
wiederkehrendes Verbrechen auch in der
heutigen Zeit ja und es ist ja so dass
wir auch oft zu
Tendenz jetzt so oft bei den Tätern
verharren und und in diesen Fällen auch
immer an die Opfer denken müssen und in
diesem Fall sollten wir also auch noch
von Renas Familie erzählen der
Journalist Oskar José cordal kann sie in
El Salvador ausfindig machen nach 30
Jahren erfährt Renas Mutter also dann
vom Tod ihrer Tochter da ist die Frau
schon 95 Jahre alt und so schrecklich
die Nachricht ist sie bringt doch
endlich Gewissheit und die Mutter
erzählt Koral dass sie die ganze Zeit
von Rena geträumt habe und in manchen
dieser Träume sei sie in einem Fass
gefangen gewesen
[Musik]
wird endlich bestattet 30 Jahre nach
ihrem Tod in El Salvador ihre Heimat
einen Monat später stirbt ihre Mutter
und es scheint fast so als habe sie nur
auf eine Nachricht von Rena gewartet sie
wird neben ihrer Tochter gesetzt
das war's für heute die Geschichte von
Rainer marokkin haben wir erzählt unter
anderem anhand von Beiträgen der New
York Post von CBS News Sun Sentinel und
forensic Files now wenn es euch gefallen
hat empfehlt uns weiter und hinterlasst
gern eine Bewertung wo immer ihr diesen
Podcast auch hört das freut uns wirklich
sehr und hilft uns auf jeden Fall weiter
diese Reihe vorzuführen danke und bis
bald euer Stefan und euer Mirko